- [Matt] Thank you, everyone,
and welcome to STG419.
Quick show of hands,
who here has been to a code talk before?
Anyone?
All right.
Who came to this session specifically
because you saw that we
were going to show code
instead of just PowerPoint slides?
Anyone?
All right, that's good.
Who came because it's after lunch
and they're looking for
a place to take a nap?
All right.
Yeah, we'll try to keep
it down for you, sir.
My name's Matt Boyd and
with me is my colleague,
Prabir Sekhri.
And we are Solutions Architects with AWS.
And today, we're going to be exploring
how to modernize your
managed file transfers,
and automate your file
transfer and file processing.
And so with that,
let me quickly walk
you through the journey
that we're gonna be taking you on today.
We're going to start by talking
about managed file
transfers, what they are,
why they matter, and some
of the building blocks
that we'll be using for our
modern file transfer service
that we'll be building today.
Then we're gonna do a quick
overview of Transfer Family
and its features.
And then we're gonna
dive into our use case
and a target architecture,
followed by a quick
sprinkling of Agentic AI
since we'll be using that
as part of our solution.
And then we're gonna get into the code.
So, we will be doing hands-on coding
and deployment in real time.
And we'll hope that nothing
breaks while we do it.
All right, so let's get started.
What is managed file transfer?
Simply put, it is the exchange
and processing of files securely often
between two known business
partners or business entities,
but it can also be between internal
or external systems in general.
And believe it or not, managed
file transfer is critical
to almost every industry
and vertical in finance.
It is used for clearing house
settlements, for example.
In logistics, it's used
for supply chain tracking.
And in any analytics use case,
you usually have to
ingest files and content
and that is also typically done
using managed file transfer
at some capacity.
And so, for most organizations,
managed file transfer is not just
the process of transferring files
but it's core to their business functions
and their business processes.
And so with that,
what many organizations
need to do is they need
to modernize their managed
file transfer systems
and move away from legacy tooling
and operational overhead.
And so, today we're gonna be showing you
how to build a modern MFT system.
And these are just some
of the building blocks
that we're going to be using today.
First, we're gonna be
using AWS Transfer Family,
fully managed service for file transfers,
and I'll talk about that in a moment here.
We're also gonna implement
some malware scanning
because most organizations need to do that
when they receive malware
from an organization outside.
And so, we'll use
GuardDuty malware scanning
for S3 for that.
Now, for the Agentic
workflow or for our workflow,
after we receive that file to process it,
we're gonna remove human manual labor
and we're going to use an Agentic workflow
for that processing of
the files that we receive.
And then pulling it all together,
we're going to use infrastructure as code
and Terraform for our deployment,
and automated deployment processes,
and we'll use an event-driven architecture
with Amazon EventBridge.
So, briefly, I wanna cover
the key components of
the AWS Transfer Family.
There's actually three main services
or features within the
Transfer Family portfolio.
The first one is file transfer servers.
And these are fully managed
file transfer servers
that you can deploy very quickly
and they scale automatically.
They're backed by S3 storage
and they support the most
industry standard protocols.
SFTP, FTPS and AS2.
Now if you need to send
files to a remote SFTP server
or maybe you need to download
from a remote SFTP server,
Transfer Family offers SFTP connectors.
And SFTP connectors are
essentially a fully managed
SFTP client that you can use via an API.
So, no infrastructure to
maintain, to download,
or send files via SFTP to remote servers.
And then finally, if you
have use cases where you need
to provide web-based
access to file stored in S3
and you need to do it
securely with authentication
for human users and in a
user-friendly interface,
we have Transfer Family web apps.
This is a fully managed web
app that integrates with S3
and we'll be showing that
as part of the solution today as well.
One other call out here is that
with modern file transfers,
you often wanna adopt an
event driven architecture
and Transfer Family integrates
with Amazon EventBridge.
So, for example,
you can automatically trigger
downstream file processing
when you receive a file.
All right, so with that, I'm
gonna pass it over to Prabir
and he's gonna talk about the use case
that we're going to be building for today.
And he'll show you the current state
and then what we're going
to be building toward.
- [Prabir] Thank you, Matt.
All right, so for today's use case,
we'll be looking at modernizing
a traditional insurance
claims processing system.
I just wanna know like
with a quick show of hands,
how many of you are in like
the insurance financial services domain?
Okay, quite a few.
Nice.
And what about some other domains?
Maybe you can shout it out like
what industries are you from?
- [Audience Member] Healthcare.
- [Prabir] Healthcares.
- [Audience Member] Hospitality.
- [Prabir] Hospitality.
Perfect.
So the use case I'm showing you today
actually can be applied
or can be seen also in
other industries as well.
It's very straight in
and the way traditional
claims processing works is,
typically, it has three
different phases, right?
So, typically, we start
with the ingest phase,
which this is where you will have
most companies ingest files using SFTP.
In our insurance use case,
these could be files such
as policy documents, could be
images, and repair estimates.
We often have an extraction phase.
So this is where most
organizations do have
some kind of an OCR or basic OCR.
And for those who don't know OCR,
it's basically a technique that's used
to extract text from images.
And the challenge of basic OCR
is that it is somewhat rigid,
and it only expects files,
and formats in a certain way.
And finally in our analysis phase,
this is where you may have
some kind of manual processing,
you may have some intelligence
with rules-based engines,
but most of the times,
it is manually processed.
And the challenge with
all this approach is
that not only this is error prone,
it is time consuming and
it just doesn't scale.
Now we're gonna show you
how we'll transform this,
using cloud native architecture.
Now here's a modern
approach for this use case
which demonstrates all the
principles that Matt spoke about.
We'll be using secure file
transfer with Transfer Family,
we'll be setting up malware
scanning using GuardDuty,
and we will be leveraging
agents, AI agents,
to do the manual processing.
Now, all of this architecture
is gonna be orchestrated,
using EventBridge.
And yeah, without further ado,
I'm gonna dive deep into each layer.
I'm gonna talk about it a little bit more.
Now our stage one is
where we are building a secure foundation.
We're gonna be starting
with replacing our legacy SFTP
servers with Transfer Family,
which means that there's no
infrastructure to manage.
It offers automatic scaling
and high durability.
Now we want to authenticate
external users, right?
These could be, especially
for our use case,
external partners, repair shops,
and we wanna do it in a secure way
without managing identity.
So this is where we're gonna be leveraging
our Transfer Family's custom
identity provider toolkit.
And Matt's gonna do a demo
on that in a little bit
and just in a while.
But by using that,
you don't have to manage
separate credentials,
you can integrate with your
partners and then key provider.
It could be anywhere from
Okta, from Ping, from Entra.
And you wanna store
everything in Amazon S3
for its unlimited scalability
and high durability.
Now moving on to our next stage,
we want to add automatic
malware protection.
GuardDuty will scan
every file as it arrives.
It offers immediate threat detection
and intelligent routing.
What I mean by that is
that you'll have all your clean files
that are gonna be automatically
moved to a clean bucket,
and any malicious file
or a suspicious file will move
to a quarantine bucket automatically.
All done through event-driven approach.
And moving on,
this is where we're seeing
a major transformation
in how organizations are processing files
or modernizing, I would
say, file transfers.
This is where we're
gonna be using AI agents
to replace somewhat of
the manual processing.
We're gonna be using
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
that's gonna be our
orchestrator for all our agents.
And the agents themselves,
they can use the most sophisticated models
that are available not only in Bedrock
but also from other cloud
providers or other partners.
So, you know, providers such as Anthropic,
even our own Amazon Nova models.
And these, in general,
provide a lot more flexibility
and higher accuracy than traditional OCR.
Now with just this approach
alone, we've now automated
what used to takes maybe a
team of people hours to days,
and that's something can be done
in just a couple of seconds or minutes.
Now let's make all of this
accessible to our human users.
Now this is where we're
gonna be leveraging
Transfer Family's web
UI or web apps service.
This is especially for your end users
because you don't have to
know SFTP commands, right?
It's offered a simple
browser-based access.
It is completely self-served
and has security built-ins,
which means that you can have
rules based access, right?
People have access to the right files
and at the right time.
Built on the principles of zero trust.
Now we're gonna be deploying
all of this using Terraform,
the Transfer Family service team.
And, in fact, it's endorsed
by our solution architects
'cause we build this, we
support an official module
that is available in
the Terraform registry.
By the way, anybody using
these Terraform modules
from Transit Family?
You are?
Oh, great, awesome.
Anybody using Terraform
in general to automate?
Perfect, beautiful, great, awesome.
So, you're gonna really enjoy
what we have for you today.
And for those who are not
using our modules, this is,
you know, I strongly encourage
you to use our modules.
That's perfect.
Using modules basically allows you
to improve standardization.
You can deploy all of your infrastructure
across your environments
in a standardized way.
And you widely wanna track
everything in Git, right?
For tracking of changes
for rollbacks and auditing.
And lastly, we recommend
that you deploy everything
using the CI/CD pipeline.
All right, now it's time to build.
Now we're gonna go start
getting into the code
and if you wanna see the
actual code yourself,
please grab the QR code.
It will take you to the GitHub repository
that we have for you and also the branch,
specific branch that we're
gonna be working off of.
We'll share the QR code again in the end.
So for those who have missed
it, that's perfectly okay.
We're gonna be showing this
a couple of times actually.
Yep, all right.
I'll just give everybody maybe 10 seconds.
I see some people are
still trying to record.
All right.
So I think, Matt, you have
some stuff to show them, right?
- [Matt] I do.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
Why don't you take it away?
- So, before we get into
the first part of the code here,
I'm gonna show you what
we're gonna be building
and you may have caught it.
Prabir was showing the various stages of
our architecture stage one through four.
And that's actually how
we're gonna be building
out our architecture
today into various stages.
So, the first stage is
to create our AWS Transfer Family server.
And so, we'll be using the
Terraform modules for that,
but we also need to
incorporate authentication.
And so, that is where
we're going to be deploying
the Transfer Family custom
identity provider solution.
And I'll talk a little bit more on that
when we get into the code itself.
But it's essentially a
solution that is endorsed
by the Transfer Family service team
for integrating the most
popular identity providers.
And we have a prebuilt
Terraform module for this
as well that I will show you.
So, with that, I'm gonna go
ahead and get into the code
and, Prabir, if you could switch me over.
- [Prabir] There you go.
- [Matt] And we are now
in the terminal here.
And so, very briefly and again,
you'll be able to see
this if you go to the code
in GitHub after the the session.
We've structured our Terraform
into various stages here
and we have a couple of additional modules
that we put into this solution.
And so, first,
the first stage is our Transfer
Family server stage here.
We did also deploy a
couple of prerequisites.
IAM Identity Center, Cognito User Pool,
that's in stage zero,
but we've already deployed that.
So, before I go into the code,
I'm gonna go ahead and
start the deployment
and we have several
scripts that just help us
with getting the deployment going.
And we will do stage1-deploy.sh.
And this is just quickly showing
what we're actually deploying here.
So we have Terraform apply
and then we're using a variables file
and I'll show you that
variables file briefly here.
We've actually broken up the
solution into different stages
with feature flags in our Terraform.
And that's really how we're
controlling what we deploy
and when throughout this.
Obviously, in most environments,
you would not need to stage like this,
but we're doing it for the
purpose of the code talk.
Let's kick off the deployment
and while that builds,
I will jump over to stage
one, our transfer server.
So, a couple key call outs here.
The first thing that we
are actually building,
and I'm gonna bring this
down to give us some space,
is our custom identity provider solution.
And so, for that, we're
using the Terraform
for AWS Transfer Family Custom IDP module,
that is already available
in the GitHub repository.
So, this really simplifies
the deployment of the
custom IDP solution itself,
which consists of a Lambda function
with authentication logic
and modules for various
identity providers.
And then DynamoDB tables that
are used for configuration.
And then, for some identity providers,
they can't be reached
over public internet,
and you may need to attach them to a VPC.
And so, in order to do that,
you can modify this used VPC parameter,
set that to true, and you
can specify the subnets,
and the security groups that you need
to attach the Lambda function to,
so that it can communicate
with your identity provider.
There's several other optional features.
For example, you can put an API gateway,
API in front of the Lambda function.
If, for example, you want to attach
a web application firewall
for additional security,
but this is really all
you need out of the box
for this custom IDP solution
to be deployed with Terraform.
Now the second thing we need to do
once we've deployed the
custom IDP solution is we need
to create our Transfer Family server.
And again,
we're going to use the Transfer
Family Terraform module
for that.
And in order to configure
the Transfer Family server,
we have a couple of parameters here.
The first one is our domain.
So we'll configure either
S3 or EFS for the storage.
In this case, we're going to be using S3
and then we have options
for the endpoint type
and the protocol.
So we're going to set
this to a public endpoint,
but you could also attach this to a VPC.
For example, if you wanted
to run a private SFTP server.
And then for a protocol,
we're going to be using SFTP protocol.
Now for configuring authentication itself,
we need to change the
identity provider parameter
to AWS Lambda instead of service managed.
And then we need to specify the ARN
of our custom IDP Lambda,
which is one of the
outputs from the module.
And so, that's what we've done here.
And you can see now, this
will wire up authentication
to forward all authentication requests
to our Lambda function.
- [Prabir] Hey, Matt,
before you go further,
so this is cool,
but I wanna understand like
how do you manage users
and how do you map them to
these identity providers?
- [Matt] Yeah, that's a
great question, Prabir.
And actually, all of this is done
via configuration in DynamoDB tables.
And so, there's a couple of ways for you
to configure those DynamoDB records.
Terraform is one option,
but you could do that,
do it externally as well.
And the solution has really two tables.
One is for the identity
provider configuration
and that's what this
DynamoDB table item record
in Terraform represents.
We give our provider a name.
In this case, it's Cognito Pool
because our repair shops are going
to authenticate via an
existing Cognito User Pool.
And then we specify the configuration.
And in the Cognito configuration,
we need to specify an app
client ID for our user pool
and then the region that
the user pool resides in.
Then when it comes to the user,
we can create records
for each individual user.
And in this record, we have our user,
in this case, it's actually
the any company repairs user,
but we're using a variable
to specify the username.
And then you link your users
to the identity provider
that you've created in your
identity provider's table.
So, in this case, the
Cognito Pool Provider.
From there, you specify what access
and entitlements are going to give
for that Transfer Family session.
So, Transfer Family supports
this concept of logical directories
or virtual directories
where you can map any
path on the SFTP server
to an S3 bucket or an EFS volume.
In this case, I'm mapping
the root folder to a bucket
that we have provisioned where our claims
that we're uploading are
going to land initially.
So, our deployment looks
like it is complete
and I've got some output here.
We can see our Transfer
Family server endpoint
and I have a test script just to make sure
that everything is
functioning as expected.
So we're gonna go ahead and
test out this code quick
that we've deployed.
And we'll do stage1-test.sh.
So what we're gonna do quickly
is retrieve credentials
that we stored in Secrets Manager
and we're gonna use those to authenticate
to the Transfer Family session.
And you can see, our SFTP session is going
to use any company dash
repairs as the user.
So let's go ahead and kick that off.
Say yes to the fingerprint.
And I'll enter my password.
Now when I enter my
password, if it's successful,
we'll immediately upload
one of our claims files,
just as a test.
And it looks like we were able to upload
that file successfully.
So that's a good sign.
The last thing we're gonna do,
just to make sure everything
is working as expected,
is verify that that file
is indeed in the S3 bucket
where we expect it to be.
And simple S3 LS, we can
see claim-1.zip was uploaded
and we are all set.
So, in this stage,
we just quickly built a
Transfer Family server,
we integrated the custom IDP solution,
and we integrated our Cognito
users for authentication.
And so with that, Prabir,
I think our next step is
to implement some malware scanning.
Is that right?
- [Prabir] Yeah, that's right.
Quiz time.
Do you remember which service we intended
to use for malware protection?
GuardDuty.
There you go, somebody's paying attention.
Perfect.
So, for anybody using GuardDuty
for malware scanning today?
All right, I see a few people over there.
So if you're using GuardDuty
for malware scanning,
so the way the GuardDuty works is that,
it scans every object that
lands into a protected S3 bucket
and the way it does it
that it adds an object tag
based on the scan results.
So, if it's a clean object,
it'll add a clean tag.
If it's a malicious object,
it will add, no threats found tag.
And what we've done with this is that,
we've expanded this architecture
to leverage event-driven approach.
So, we have EventBridge
that is listening to GuardDuty events.
And the scan results are
being passed on EventBridge
to an SQS Queue.
Now we've added SQS Queue
just as a matter of decoupling
in best practice so that we
can scale and offer resiliency,
but also like if our downstream
processing is unavailable,
we can always replay
these messages using SQS.
Now, SQS further triggers
our Lambda function.
So our Lambda function is
basically reading off all
the events in our SQS
Queue and processing them.
Lambda over here is kind of the brain
or the logic that decides
based on the scan results,
which files to be routed to which bucket.
So, once again, clean files
will go to a clean bucket,
malicious file will go
to a quarantine bucket,
and any object that is not
treated or is not processed,
will go to our error bucket.
Optionally, in this module,
we've also added a
dead-letter queue in SQS.
So, any messages in the
queue that are not processed,
we want to actually store them too
because we wanna investigate what happened
and process them at a later stage.
And we've also had the
ability to send notifications
through SNS.
We believe this is actually very important
'cause if you have a malware
in one of your accounts
or your buckets, you wanna
get notified immediately.
So this is an optional feature
and we'll be showing that
in the code right away.
Matt, do you mind switching
to the demo screen?
- [Matt] Happy to.
- [Prabir] Awesome.
So, before I show you the code,
I'm just gonna kick off the deployment.
So, again, I'm using
these beautiful scripts
that Matt put together.
And once again, very simply,
it's just doing a Terraform apply.
It's not the screen from the matrix,
it's definitely doing a Terraform apply
if you've already seen that.
All right, so, the Terraform module
for malware protection is
actually pretty simple.
So you can see it is available
as a sub-module in our Transfer
Family malware protection,
Transfer Family server module.
And it requires primarily
three different things.
Number one, you have to
specify a source bucket
or a bucket that needs protection, right?
So, in this case,
it's defined using our
S3 ingest bucket block.
I am actually referencing a bucket
that was created in one
of our previous stages
and it is the same bucket that Matt sent
and created an SFTP file to.
The second part of
the configuration is our optional feature.
So this is where we can
specify an SNS topic
for malware detection and,
optionally, a dead-letter queue.
So, all those configurations,
we've kept them as true
as best practices default,
is to show that this works out of the box.
The main thing you wanna know is
that we have a routing config.
So, the routing config
maps GuardDuty events.
So these are the exact same events.
So, some of you said
that you use GuardDuty,
these are the exact same
events that GuardDuty emits.
So, for example, if the file was clean,
GuardDuty will put in
a no threats found tag
to one of our buckets.
And you see that this is being
mapped to a clean bucket.
This could be any of the buckets
that you've created from maybe
if you have another module
that you use to create S3 buckets.
So you can refer them as well.
For any object that was
considered malicious,
we'll have a threats found tag,
which will move to our quarantine bucket.
And any objects that were
not processed by GuardDuty,
maybe there was a permission issue,
maybe the object type was not supported,
was an access denied or failed,
they will automatically move
to our errors bucket
for further processing.
- [Matt] And, Prabir,
I just wanna make sure
that I understand this correctly.
This isn't ties specifically
to the Transfer Family service.
Like you could use this
for really any solution
where you need malware
scanning and S3, right?
- [Prabir] Yeah, that's right.
So, the way we build these modules,
they're really independent
building blocks or Lego pieces.
You can take this module, let's say,
you already have a pipeline
that deploys all of the above, right?
VPCs, Transfer Family servers,
maybe identity provider,
maybe you're managing it
separately using confirmation,
that's absolutely fine,
but you want to add malware protection.
You can just take this module
and deploy it in any of
your Terraform pipelines.
So this will work out of the box.
And that's, in fact, how we
build all the other modules too.
So you don't have to use everything
or everything we exampled from
to have a full feature deployment.
You can really plug and play.
Yep.
- That's awesome.
- [Prabir] Great, thank you.
So let's test our malware protection.
Oh, I don't want to add
anything on the code.
So let me go backtrack.
All right, stage two test.
So once again, we are
using some helper scripts
that are just simulating
the same kind of flow.
The first thing we're gonna
do is that we are going
to connect to our SFTP server.
So I'm gonna start the SFTP session.
I'm gonna enter my password
for the SFTP server.
Now I see that my
claim-1 file was updated.
At the same time, I also
added an EICAR file.
Does anybody know what an EICAR file is?
Perfect.
So, an EICAR file is a way for you
to test malware protection
without compromising a system.
You actually don't wanna
inject an actual malware
to test if your malware
protection's working.
You know, that's not a good idea.
What if your system gets infected?
So, EICAR files are a great way to like,
test malware protection.
So in this case, we are
parsing CloudWatch logs
and we see that GuardDuty
did pick these up
as appropriately.
So, our claim file was
tagged as no threats found.
And our malicious file,
which is what I call file,
was detected as threats found.
Now I'm just gonna do an
S3 LS on our clean bucket
to see if the files did land
in the right place or not.
So, firstly, if I see in my claims bucket.
Yeah, actually, that was over here.
So I did see that my file
was processed properly,
my clean file landed
in my S3 clean bucket.
If I look at my quarantine bucket,
I do see that my EICAR
file was successfully moved
to our quarantine bucket.
And again, all done through
different architecture.
I didn't have to make any
manual changes on my side.
All right.
Now I think it's a good moment
for us to talk about agents
or Agentic AI.
How many of you are using agents
or AI aviation agents, are exploring
with AI agents today,
whether it's in test?
Okay, a few of you.
So, for those who are not using AI agents,
this architecture actually
might look very familiar.
You know, let's say if you have a,
some kind of file processing pipeline
that uses intelligence.
Intelligence, what I mean by intelligence,
is it uses some of our AI services.
There were just a lot more
steps involved in building
something that does like, I
would say, file processing.
And these steps were
basically Lambda functions
or step functions that
basically we'll call different.
It'll be a services.
The thing I'm gonna call out
that this architecture
is still very relevant.
So if you have a very, I would say,
a pipeline that's very, I would say,
very strict in terms of
like you know exactly
what needs to be
processed and what orders,
this is perfect, this scale really well.
But for organizations that are looking
at a little more flexibility,
this is where agents are
really, really powerful.
Now, for this use case,
we're gonna be using
an Agentic AI workflow
and we're gonna be
orchestrating all our agents,
using Amazon Bedrock Agent Core.
We built all these agents
using the strands SDK,
which is an open source framework
that AWS has developed for
you to like build agents
and offers a lot more flexibility.
And I'm gonna talk about
it just in a second.
We have a couple of different agents.
I'm gonna talk about the
agents that are in the middle.
So, I have an entity detection agent.
What it's doing is that,
its job is to extract
text from a PDF file.
I have a validation agent
that actually is built on the
principles of multimodality.
So, it will take text and
will also read the image
and then compare if the text
matches with the image or not.
I have built a summarization agent
that summarizes all the findings
from the previous agents
and I have a database agent
that basically takes all the
entities that are detected
and pushes them to a DynamoDB table.
The brain behind all of this
is our supervisor agent,
which is coordinating all the tasks
between the other sub-agents.
So the supervisor agent
kind of decides where,
which agent to invoke at what time.
Now the thing I wanna mention is
that this patent is
actually not only relevant
for insurance customer,
but it can be applied to
any industries, right?
Somebody mentioned healthcare,
like maybe if you're in
like maybe in finance,
this kind of flow
and this kind of architecture
works really, really well.
It's just that you have to
change the prompt a little bit.
And speaking of prompts,
let me actually show you
how I build these agents very quickly
in terms of the prompts.
So, we have our claim files.
The first thing I'm doing
is that I've actually tasked
the entity detection agent
and I'm using simple natural
language to build my prompt.
I'm asking it to extract this information
from this card damage claim
and ingest it in a JSON format.
I'm asking my validation agent
to analyze this card damage image
against a reported claim details.
I'm asking my summarization agent
to summarize all of the findings
into this specific format
that I'm showing you over here.
And lastly, I have my database agent
and I've instructed it in natural language
to extract all these entities
and push them into a DynamoDB table.
All right, so let's talk about
how I build this in code.
Matt, do you mind switching
to the demo, please?
- [Matt] Sure.
There we go.
- [Prabir] Awesome.
So the first thing I'm gonna
do is kick off the deployment.
Now I wanna quickly walk
you through the architecture
and how we've built these modules.
So the first thing I wanna mention is that
we are using one of our
modules for Agent Core.
This is a module that it supports
out of the box, you know,
of supported officially.
So we're using one of them,
but the thing I wanna show you is actually
how we build these agents using strands.
Anybody using strands by the way today
or played around with strands?
Okay.
- We got one.
- We got one?
Okay, perfect, I can see.
Great, awesome.
So for those who have used strands,
or this might look very familiar,
but for those who haven't used strands,
strands actually works on
three different concepts
or three different
things that it requires.
So the first thing that strands require is
that the agent needs
to have a model, right?
So the model is basically
the brain for the AI.
The second thing that the
agent needs is a tool.
Now a tool, in very
simple terms, is an action
that you provide to the agent
and an action that the
AI agent can perform.
This action could be a function, right?
Something that you specify
or that you do a task
or it could be another sub-agent, right?
That this agent, this
orchestrated agent, can use.
So it's, basically, you're
giving the AI hands to,
you know, track with the outside world.
Now I've built a couple of
tools for my orchestrator agent.
I'm gonna show you an
example of one of them.
The tool that I've built
over here is actually
a very simple function that
calls one of our sub-agents,
which is the entity extraction agent.
And, you know, for those who
are familiar with programming,
what I'm doing is pretty simple.
The first thing I'm actually asking is
to extract the ARN off my
entity detection agent.
In my step two, I'm actually
ingesting a payload,
which is my bucket name and my object name
or the PDF key, right?
Which is gonna be our claims
forms that we'll be testing.
I'm creating a unique session ID,
and again, I've done this
just for best practices.
I wanna troubleshoot every
session in CloudWatch.
And in step four, I'm in actually,
this is the place where I'm invoking
the entity extraction agent Bedrock.
And lastly, my final step, I'm
just parsing all the outputs
that have been generated from this agent.
And then this orchestrated
agent can read them
and proceed to the next step.
Now I've built the other
agents in a similar way.
So you see that I have like
the fraud detection agent specification,
I have the database insertion agents.
It's basically just calling these agents.
But the thing I wanna show
you over here is this.
Now,
for those who have interacted
with some kind of text-based or ALM based,
you know, surveys, even ChatGPT,
this might actually look very familiar.
So instead of using complex logic, right?
Statements written in
SQL or whatnot, right?
I am instructing this
agent in natural language
to do the following, right?
So I've given it a task.
I've said that you are a claims
processing workflow agent,
leveraging strands.
I'm saying that your job
is to extract entities,
validate the damage consistency,
insert all this data into a database,
and generate a summary.
Now the agent decides, based
on this task I've given,
which tools to use.
And you saw, like,
I showed one of the tools
the way I've configured it.
So the agent decided,
"You know what, okay.
I need to extract entities.
I know that I have a tool for that,
which is my subagent, so I can call that."
So that's how we've built this in strands.
And again, a fun fact is
that I've built this
in a couple of minutes.
So, you know, we were using QL CLI.
So for those who are using QL
or any other AI powered coding assistant,
this can be done very, very quickly.
So all you have to do is
just put your business logic,
ask you to build something in strands,
and you'll have your
agent take AI workflow.
All right.
Now before I test the agents,
I'm gonna show you what
the claim files look like.
So I have two sample claim files.
On my left, I have a claims
record that shows....
Let me come here actually.
A car that was damaged in a parking lot.
We have a rear bumper damage
that happened in a parking lot
and the estimated cost
to repair it is $995,
if I'm not mistaken.
And if you look at the image,
this is very consistent to what we see,
but on my right hand
side, I have a claim form
that states that this was actually
a minor front bumper scratch
that happened in a
grocery store parking lot.
And I don't know, like,
do you think that this is a minor scratch?
- [Matt] Doesn't look like
a minor scratch to me.
- [Prabir] I know.
- [Matt] Yeah, I would say
that's a little more than a minor scratch
in a parking lot.
- [Prabir] Yeah, yeah.
And by the way, no cars were harmed
in making this demo, right?
So, just wanna call that out.
Sort in a very, very
expensive demo otherwise.
Awesome.
So, let's test this,
Matt, what do you think?
- [Matt] Yeah, let's try it out.
I'm gonna switch back to the demo.
- [Prabir] All right.
So, once again, we're using a test script.
Same flow, our event driven
architecture's gonna kick in.
We're gonna log in to the RSTFP server.
We're gonna enter a password.
And we've uploaded one of our claim files.
And one thing we've did with the script is
that we've asked it to
parse CloudWatch logs.
So we have like five different agents.
We thought that the best use of our time
wouldn't have been to go in the console,
find CloudWatch logs.
Who likes, you know, going
to the console, by the way?
Anybody?
- [Matt] No one likes, I like the console.
- [Prabir] The console's cool.
Yeah, yeah.
- Let's not be too mean.
- [Prabir] So, everybody likes
to go code being like the ID?
Yeah, that's why I see the team over here.
Yeah, cool.
- [Matt] I guess that's the right answer.
- [Prabir] Perfect, cool.
Maybe, I don't know.
All right, so we see that
our CloudWatch logs picked up
different things that are
happening in our workflow.
So we see, the first thing we found that,
I'm just gonna scroll up just in a bit.
We see our entity
detection agent picked up
all these entities, right?
Our fraud validation agent,
again, took this data and
it's now reading the image
that I've supplied with it.
Our workflow agent is our orchestrator.
So, again, it's kind of showing
a different orchestration
that's going on.
And our database agent again
took all these entities
and now it's meaningfully parsing it
and ingesting into DynamoDB record.
All right.
So, I see that our claims
processing was finished
and I'm gonna show you
the claim in a minute.
All right, so I see that my
claim was successfully processed
and I'm gonna move on to
the second claim as well.
I'm gonna test both of them
and I'm gonna see them at the same time.
Okay, so I have uploaded this file.
I know for those who like the console,
let's actually go to the console
and see what's happening.
Okay, if we've created a
couple of different buckets.
I will be in my clean bucket
because all these files were clean
and I can see that my claim
was successfully uploaded.
I just uploaded my claim two,
so it's still being processed,
but at the same time, I
have these two prefixes.
So I have my submitted claims,
I see the claim one that was submitted.
So this is very consistent with the image
and the PDF that I showed to you.
And our process claim was the one
that was just processed by the AI agent.
Sorry, I'm in the same prefix again.
So, if I open this summary,
let just make it slightly bigger.
So this claim is claim one.
We saw that this was a
claim that had, you know,
that said that it was had
a minor rear bumper damage.
The estimated cost to
repair this claim was $995.
And this is what my summarization
agent, by the way, did.
So it states that, our fraud agent said,
the fraud agent is 90% confident
that the description matches the image.
The analysis, again, all
done in natural language,
which says that this is a car
that had a minor bumper damage.
It's very consistent with
the claim description.
There's a visible denting
on the rear bumper
and there's no apparent
damage on the vehicle.
And the recommendation by this
agent to our human agents is
that this claim can be approved.
So, again, this is super, super powerful.
Just eliminate a whole
bunch of manual steps
that human users have to do.
Now at the same time, let me-
- [Matt] Let's see the second one.
- [Prabir] Yeah, let's see,
I'm curious about that.
Let's see if it processed.
Okay, so my second
claim is also processed.
I think it should be
the first one over here.
All right.
Yes, legible, okay, perfect.
- Yeah.
- So my second claim,
again, our claim forms stated
that this was a minor front bumper scratch
and the estimated cost
to repair, that was $350.
But our AI agent said
that this is actually,
the image does not match the description
and the agent is 95% confident.
So even more confident in that
this is not a scratch, right?
So that's exactly what it states.
It says that, although the claim suggests
that this is a front bumper scratch,
but the image shows
severe front-end damage.
And it suggests that this
claim should be reviewed for
by a human just to be sure.
So, you know, the thing
I wanna call out as
that is this shows how
powerful this workflow can be
and how you can apply
this in your use cases.
And I build this using simple
natural language prompts.
The power of this is that you
can literally take our demo,
maybe play around with the prompts,
and have something up and running
for your own use cases too.
The one thing I do wanna call out is
that I don't think that, you know,
our business users will
like going to the ID.
I know all of us,
we do like the ID, right?
- Yeah.
Or the AWS console maybe.
- [Prabir] Yeah, not even that.
- [Matt] Be able to advance for someone
that needs to review
insurance claims, right?
- [Prabir] So what do you think, Matt,
we should do for that?
- [Matt] Well, I think
this would be a good time
to implement Transfer Family web apps.
- [Prabir] Okay, take it away.
- [Matt] So why don't we do that
and I'm gonna grab this,
switch back to our PowerPoint.
So, the last stage,
now that we've created
this awesome workflow
where we're automating the
file or the claims processing,
and summarizing it, looking
for the potential for fraud,
is we need to make this
available to the humans
that are gonna do this final review
and sign off on these claims, right?
And so, we'll call those
our claims reviewers
and we're gonna give them access using
a Transfer Family web app.
So, show of hands,
is anybody using Transfer
Family web apps at all
or explored it?
Awesome.
And so, anybody here use a
service called S3 Access Grants?
Yes, obviously, if you use web apps,
you use S3 Access Grants.
Good, good answer.
So, we're gonna be using
a combination of these services today.
I'm gonna briefly, for those not familiar,
walk through how this service works.
So, when you deploy a web app,
you integrate it with
another AWS service called,
IAM Identity Center.
And Identity Center supports
federated authentication
from identity providers, Okta,
Entra, just to name a few.
But really any SAML based
identity provider can integrate
with Identity Center,
and that's how your end
users will authenticate.
They'll authenticate
through Identity Center
and then be redirected
back to the web app.
But then we need to
assign them permissions
and authorizations.
And that is done through
another service called,
S3 Access Grants.
And in order to do this,
we first define an S3 bucket location
with our Access Grants.
And so this is where we're
going to specify a location
to assign grants or permissions to.
And then we're going to
assign individual grants
for our users or groups.
And in the table in the lower left,
that's the grants that we'll be assigning.
And you can see that our
claims reviewers group will be
given read only access
to the submitted claims
and process claims buckets.
And then we'll have a claims admin group.
If they need to manage
the files in the bucket,
we'll give them read and write access.
So we're gonna set all of this up.
Now the one thing I want
you to be aware of is
if you've ever had to
configure all of this
in the console, especially
the Access Grants
and setting up and
assigning the permissions,
you may find that it's a lot of clicks,
it's a lot of manual processes,
looking up user IDs based
on their display names.
So we're gonna automate all of that
with Terraform here in just a moment.
So let's switch over, Prabir.
And again, I'm gonna go ahead
and kick off our deployment
before we show the code.
And we'll go over this.
Okay, so what we're gonna
do today is show you
what we're calling the alpha module of
the Transfer Family web app for Terraform.
And this is something that
we haven't released yet,
but it is in the source code
that we're sharing a link with today.
And it's something that we are hoping
to release here very shortly.
But this, what we expect
this will allow you
to do is really simplify
deploying Transfer Family web apps
and configuring your S3 Access Grants
for your user entitlements.
This is made up of one
main module for the web app
and then two sub-modules,
which I'm gonna walk through here quickly.
So, first, we use our
transfer web app module itself
and this is what's going
to actually deploy the
Transfer Family web app.
And a web app is actually
really easy to deploy.
It's fully managed.
With a couple clicks in the console,
you can deploy a web app in
the Transfer Family console.
And, really, all we need
to do is specify the name
that we wanna assign our web app,
and then we need to connect it
with an IAM Identity Center instance
and an S3 access grant instance.
And, usually, these are both
in the same AWS account.
However, if you already have
an organization-wide
identity center instance,
you can use that instead of
an account based instance.
So, in a couple lines of code,
we have our web app deployed.
Now we need to configure our permissions
and we have a sub-module first
that will define the S3 locations
where we're going to be giving
users access for in web apps.
So, what this module is
doing is configuring this in
at the S3 Access Grants instance,
and it's automatically
creating an IAM role
with the associated permissions
and trust policy required.
And it can optionally
create a bucket for us
if we wanna specify a clean bucket
that we're gonna be using.
Or in this case, we're gonna
be using an existing bucket
which has those process claims.
The other thing that it can do,
and this is a requirement
when you're configuring
Transfer Family web apps,
is we're gonna set the
course configuration
on our S3 bucket.
So you need to do this for any S3 bucket
that you configure with web apps.
And so, this will also do
that for you automatically
as well.
Now the last piece is to
configure the entitlements
or the permissions themselves.
And that's where this web app users
and groups module comes in.
And again, this is a sub-module
that will be under the
transfer web apps module
because it's purpose built for web apps.
And we can define both user
and group entitlements via the
users and groups parameters.
In this case, we're doing
role-based access controls.
So we're assigning groups.
And, first, we specify the
display name for our group.
Now I'll show you in
the console in a moment,
what this actually does is
it looks up the the group ID,
which is a UUID of that
group in Identity Center.
And it retrieves that
and we'll use that for the configuration.
So it's simplifying a lot of
that process of doing look ups.
And then we assign our
actual Access Grants.
In other words, the permissions
that we are going to give to this group.
In this case, for our claims admins,
we're gonna assign read-write access
to our S3 bucket location
that we defined in the previous step.
We're gonna give it access
to the entire bucket.
So all paths with that wild card.
Now for our claims reviewers,
very similar setup except we're going
to have two Access Grants assigned.
First, we're going to give
read access to submitted claims
and any sub-files and folders.
And then, to process claims as well.
So, let's check on the
status of our deployment
and it looks like we
deployed successfully.
So, there's nothing to test
in the terminal at this time.
I'm gonna take you to the actual console
because this is a human interface.
Quickly, what I want to show
you is what we just created.
So, this is our Transfer Family web app
that was just provisioned.
If we go into our web app,
we can see the configuration
including our Identity Center
instance being configured.
And if we go to the groups tab,
we can see that both of our
groups have been assigned.
These are the group IDs
that I talked about.
So these are just UUIDs that are unique
that you would otherwise have
to look up manually yourself.
So, we've really simplified
that process with this module.
And now, I'll jump over
to S3 Access Grants.
Actually, I'll just
switch over to this tab
and if we go into the details here,
we can see we have our location set up.
In this case, our claims bucket
with our clean and process claims.
And then our grants.
So, you can see our grant
IDs for our claims reviewer
and claims admin groups.
And the grant scopes
and permissions that have been applied.
So, all of that was done
with just a couple of
lines of Terraform code.
So what does it actually look
like once you authenticate,
let's go back to web apps
and we will open up our web apps URL.
We'll sign in as our claims reviewer here.
And I'm gonna make this, I'm
not gonna turn up the volume,
I'm gonna make this just
a little bit larger,
maybe too large, but we'll see.
I'm gonna remember my password hopefully.
All right, so,
now we're in our user friendly
transfer web app interface.
And if we look here,
we have access to both the
processed and submitted claims,
read permission.
If we go into our process claims,
we can open one of our claims folders
and download that same summary
that Prabir showed us earlier.
One other thing to call out here is
there is some level of
customization you can do
with these web apps.
So, if you need a custom logo
or you wanna use your organization's logo,
you can specify that in the configuration,
and that will show up here
instead of the transfer web
app icon that's right here.
And this also is a little small,
so I'll make that slightly larger
now that's we've already gone through it.
All right, so that, I think,
is the end of our architecture.
And just to quickly recap
what we've done today.
So, we configured a Transfer Family server
with authentication to an
external identity provider.
In this case, it was Cognito.
We did malware scanning automatically.
Once we received files,
we then used Agentic AI
to process our submitted claims,
look and see if there
was an inaccuracy issue.
And then we made those claims
once processed available
to our claims reviewers.
So, with that, Prabir,
where do we go from here?
What are our next steps?
- Yeah, for sure.
So I just wanna say before we wrap up,
all the code that you saw today is powered
by our Transfer Family Terraform module.
And this is available
to you for it to use,
you know, whenever you can.
And the step-by-step example
that we covered today
is one of many examples
that exist in our repository.
So it's built typically around use cases.
So if you have a specific use case,
we showed you different
components that is connectors.
But today, we showed you a
use case with Agentic AI.
All of these can be deployed
in just a couple of minutes.
So, again, very, very
quickly for you to set up,
especially if you're using
infrastructure as code.
We launched this module only
just a couple of months ago
and we've already had
over 10,000 downloads.
And I just wanna thank all
the AWS solution architects
that are basically contributing to this,
but also folks like you, you know,
we've had a lot of
external contributions too.
So if you're one of
them, thank you so much.
You can grab this QR
code for direct access.
This will take you to the
the root of the module,
which has all the examples
and has all the modules that
you can use in your folk flows.
One thing I wanna call
out is that we do maintain
a public roadmap for all the
things that we're working on.
So if you like any of the
features that we're working on,
you can always do a plus one on them.
But if you feel that there's something
that we do not support, if
you have any suggestions,
you can always create a GitHub issue.
My team and I, we review
these almost daily
because we wanna get new features
for you as soon as possible.
And I'm super excited to see
what you'll build next with these tools.
So with that, I just wanna
thank you for your time
and I hope you enjoy
the rest of re:Invent.
Thank you.
- Have a great week, everyone.